vor 100 Jahren wurde die Türkische
Republik gegründet was ist geblieben von
den Idealen des Staatsgründers Mustafa
Kemal
attür kaum ein anderer Präsident seit
attattirk hat die Republik so stark
geprägt und verändert wie Reb t erdan
seit 20 Jahren ist er an der Macht 100
Jahre
eine Erfolgsgeschichte für die einen
Leidensgeschichte für
andere wie denken die die heute in der
Türkei leben über ihre Heimat sechs von
ihnen werden ihre Geschichten in diesem
Film
[Musik]
[Applaus]
erzählen
[Musik]
ich bin Fatma Bostan ich lebe in jukar
islah ich bin Hausfrau mein Leben
verbringe ich im
[Musik]
Dorf die Berge in der Provinz Riese an
der Schwarzmeerküste im Nordosten der
Türkei es ist die Zeit der teernte auch
Fatma Bost Familie hat Teeplantagen seit
generationenon leben die bostans in
diesem Tal man blieb meist unter sich
doch die Zeiten haben sich
[Musik]
geändert damals war alles ganz anders
wenn es da ein passables Mädchen gab im
Dorf und einen Burschen dann war klar
dass man die zusammenbringt heutzutage
wollen sich die jungen Leute selbst
ihren Partner aussuchen aber das ist
auch besser
so auch Rü Bostan fatmas Ehemann und
Faris Vater stammus aus dem Dorf doch er
starb früh mit 39 22 Jahre ist das jetzt
her beigesetzt haben Sie ihn direkt
neben dem
Haus damals gab es im Dorf keinen
städtischen Friedhof weil wir hier doch
sehr weit oben Leben ich wollte meinen
verstorbenen Mann auf meinem eigenen
Grund und Boden begraben hier im Dorf
macht das jeder so meine Schwester hat
ihren Friedhof auch direkt neben ihr im
Haus war damals noch ganz klein gerade
eineinhalb seine Brüder zogen ihn groß
die haben heute selbst Familien so
kümmert sich Fari um die Mutter das sei
seine Pflicht sagt
er wenn meine Mutter weil sie das
Familienoberhaupt ist das Problem nicht
lösen kann dann eben mein Bruder mein
Onkel oder meine Tante die Familie hat
für uns große
Bedeutung seine Onkel wohnen ein Stück
weiter unten sie führen den
Familienbetrieb weiter eine
Imkerei Bienenzucht und Teeanbau haben
Tradition bei den bostans ebenso wie ihr
muslimischer
Glaube mein Vater hat sich viel Mühe
gegeben hätte es meinen Vater nicht
gegeben hätten wir hier im Dorf keine
neue Moschee er hat Geld gesammelt um
die Moschee zu bauen wir haben auch
geholfen aber das Meister hat er selbst
gemacht
ohne Religion geht es nicht das ist ein
Muss für uns es ist die Nähe zu Gott die
uns ausmacht wir haben doch sonst
[Musik]
niemanden freitags gehen sie runter in
die Moschee während der Woche betet
Fatma Bostan zu Hause fünfm am Tag unser
Leben liegt in Gottes Hand sagt sie und
in der Hand des Re ihres Präsidenten für
den sie ihr letztes Hemd
wofür wir leben für unserenruf für
unsere Religion für unsere Flagge und
für unser Land das ist unsere rote Linie
dafür stehen wir bis zum letzten Tropfen
Blut während der Erntesaison bleibt
tagsüber nicht viel Zeit zum Essen es
gibt Butter gesmolzen Käse Mais das geht
schnell erdogan hat uns Muslimen den
Stolz zurückgegeben sagt Fatma seit
Atatürks Staatsgründung waren Religion
und Staat getrennt war das Kopftuch in
öffentlichen Gebäuden
verboten meine Kinder waren beim
Militärdienst und sind krank geworden
ich wollte meinen Sohn im Krankenhaus
besuchen aber weil ich Kopftuch trage
haben sie mich nicht reingelassen sie
wollten unbedingt dass ich mein Kopftuch
abnehme aber ich bin standhaft geblieben
mussten wir heute immer noch kämpfen
nein direkt neben fatmas Haus liegt die
Teeplantage ihrer Schwester Sevim und
ihres Schwagers
abdulrahman seit Generationen bauen die
bostans Tee an alles hier oben ist
Familiensache die jungen helfen den
[Musik]
alten das Schwierigste an der Ernte ist
es auf die KN
die werden schwer mit der Zeit du hast
immer Rückenschmerzen ich bin ja keine
Maschine in jedem Jahr müssen sie drei
Ernten einbringen wenn es gut läuft
werden sie insgesamt 22 Tonnen
Teeblätter geschnitten und verkauft
[Musik]
haben die Hänge sind steil oft liegt die
nächste Straße weit entfernt dann of
groe Säcke an improvisierten Seilbahnen
ins Tal
hinunter wenn die Plantagen sehr weit
oben sind können die Seile 400 oder
sogar 500 m lang sein ist denn schon mal
ein Seil
gerissen nein mir ist das bislang noch
nicht
passiert auf der Teeplantage der bostans
hat abdulrahman die Ernte des Tages in
groe
verstaut es sind nur wenige Meter bis
zur darunterliegenden Straße so lässt er
sie einfach den Hang
hinabrollen wir müssen den Tee heute
noch verkaufen wenn er trocknet verliert
der Feuchtigkeit und bringt weniger auf
die
Waage bezahlt wird nach Gewicht nee Fari
übernimmt das Aufladen und den Transport
zur
Sammelstelle arbeitet neben der teernte
noch als Fahrer die meisten der jungen
Leute haben Jobs unten in der Stadt um
über die Runden zu kommen diese Säcke
sind die dritte und letzte Ernte in
diesem
Jahr die Firma Chur schickt einen
Experten her der den Tee wiegt und uns
einen Beleg aushändigt der Tee geht dann
direkt in die Teefabrik und wird dort
weiterverarbeitet nach ungefähr einem
Monat bekommen wir das Geld auf unser
Konto
überwiesen
Präsident Erdogan habe dafür gesorgt
dass die tepreise stabil geblieben sein
sagt Fari zusammen mit ihren Renten und
Nebenjobs kämmen sie gut über die Runden
die bostans gehören zu jenen
52% die bei der letzten Wahl für Erdogan
stimmten der Präsident habe die Türkei
zu neuer Größe geführt sagen sie ja es
gebe Probleme doch eine Nation zu führen
mein Fatma Bostan das sei schließlich
nicht einfach
atatürk hat für sein Land gekämpft und
auch Erdogan kämpft heute für sein Land
es wird immer Menschen geben die etwas
auszusetzen haben das können sie gerne
machen wir folgen Erdogan und werden das
auch weiter tun alle im Land wollen
essen und trinken und wer sorgt dafür
dass sie das tun können er Gott sagt ihm
wie er es tun soll und Erdogan folgt
diesem Rat wir sind sehr zufrieden mit
ihm
[Musik]
ich bin Türker Ertürk ich bin
pensionierter Admiral ich habe die
Marine Akademie absolviert bin 2010 aus
dem aktiven Dienst ausgetreten ich mache
seit in Politik und schreibe Kolumnen
und
Bücher
die Streitkräfte der Türkei verstehen
sich als Hüter der Republik so auch
Türker Ertürk Jahrgang
1957 Spross einer Offiziersfamilie
glühender Anhänger von Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk ehemaliger Befehlshaber der
Schwarzmeerflotte exkommandeur der
türkischen
marinaakademie
auf der See zu sein auf der See zu leben
auf der See seinen Dienst abzuleisten
eine Kriegsflotte zu befehigen das ist
ein unbeschreibliches
Gefühl und ich hatte das Glück alles
dies bereits in jungen Jahren machen zu
können mit 29 Jahren habe ich bereits
ein jagdboot
befligt Familie kämpfte in attatürks
Befreiungskrieg ertürks Großvater bekam
die unabhängigkeitsmedaille verliehen
wir haben für Atatürk und die Republik
unser Leben riskiert sagt Ertürk und
jeder der versuche diese Republik zu
unterwandern und sich gegen ihre Ideale
zu stellen sei sein
Feind ich bin 2010 aus dem Militärdienst
ausgetreten warum weil sich die Anhänger
der güen Terrororganisation in das
Militär eingeschlichen hatten und nicht
und seit ich aus dem Militärdienst den
ich so sehr geliebt habe ausgetreten bin
kämpfe ich gegen diese Infiltrierung
durch Feta gen und seine Anhänger wo ich
nur
kann Feta gen Chef einer streng
religiösen Organisation ehemaliger
Weggenosse Erdogans der ihn heute als
Terrorist bezeichnet den gen soll hinter
dem Putschversuch von 2016
stehen er habe vor der geplanten Revolte
gewarnt doch man habe nicht auf ihn
gehört damals hat die Regierung versucht
mich mundtot zu machen mich zu zensieren
keiner von denen hat heute das Recht
sich über den Putschversuch zu
beschweren es hätte verhindert werden
können aber das haben sie nicht die
Regierung hat von den Plänen gewusst und
hat Dench vers e Zwecke
missbraucht Erdogan hat den Putsch als
Gottes Geschenk bezeichnet denn die
Verhaftungen alle Operationen gegen das
Militär und gegen die Bürokratie haben
erst danach an Fahrt gewonnen es hat
eine Welle in Gang gesetzt die zum Ziel
hatte den genetischen Code des Militärs
zu verändern es ist der Versuch gewesen
den Staat unter seine eigene Kontrolle
zu
bringen
aus Protest gegen die Entmachtung der
Militärs quittiert erürk den Dienst er
geht in die Politik tritt in die CHP ein
die Partei die 1923 von Kemal Atatürk
selbst gegründet
wurde schauen Sie Atatürk ist 1938
gestorben hat das irgendeine Auswirkung
auf mich persönlich nein er ist
gestorben aus und vorbei ich fol ke
ich folge Atatürks Idee ich folge seiner
Idee der Aufklärung und das bedeutet für
mich die Abschaffung der Monarchie dass
die staatliche Souveränität in den
Händen von Menschen liegt und nicht in
den Händen Gottes und dass die Frau in
der neuen Ordnung ihren rechtmäßigen
Platz erhalten
hat für mich haben Erdogan und die die
hinter ihm stehen ein Problem mit dieser
revolutionären Aufklärung sie können
sich nicht damit
identifizieren das kann man aus Erdogans
Aussagen raushören diese Leute sehnen
sich nach dem Osmanischen Reich zurück
und brüsten sich
damit Laizismus bedeutet die strikte
Trennung von Religion und Staat Religion
hat in den Belangen des Staates der
Politik des Rechtes und der Bildung
nichts verloren erdogan ist gegenüber
dem Laizismus voreingenommen er glaubt
nicht an eine
religionsreform
[Musik]
er den repik er habe das Militär
entmachtet den Laizismus abgeschafft die
Macht müsse wieder vom Volk ausgehen
nicht von einem Mann der Präsident plane
seit langem eine Verfassungsreform damit
wolle er seine Position zementieren sagt
[Musik]
er
er ist seit 22 Jahren an der Macht und
hat es trotzdem noch nicht geschafft
diese Gesellschaft nach seinen Plänen
umzuformen der Versuch ist sicherlich da
eine neue Verfassung zu schreiben und
den Laizismus sei es auch nur auf dem
Papier
einzuschränken all das wird Erdogan
weiterhin versuchen aber ich glaube
nicht dass er damit Erfolg haben
wird ehemaligen Kollegen stehen für den
Teil der türkischen Gesellschaft die den
Kurs des Präsidenten ablehnen die Türkei
ist heute 100 Jahre nach ihrer Gründung
ein gespaltenes
Land ja man hat das türkische Militär
zum Schweigen gebracht und
eingeschüchtert aber der genetische Code
unseres Militärs wird immer derselbe
bleiben Loyalität zur Republik zu den
Ideen der Aufklärung
[Musik]
zuatürk
ich bin
silvenierin aus Diak und habe das Buch
Amidas Tisch geschrieben über die Küche
von diabak ich bin
kulturforscherin Amida nen dieenier ih
stad im Osten
derürke wieder amid Tisch decken so wie
damals als noch viele Armenier in Diab
lebten ich werde eine Art Festessen
kochen pilfreis ichchöfte und dazu noch
D früher haben wir das hier selber auf
unseren Dächern getrocknet jetzt kaufen
wir es ein für das Gericht das wir
kochen wollen brauchen wir ganz
besonders gute getrocknete
[Musik]
Tomaten auf zeigt sie uns die Orte ihrer
Kindheit oder das was davon übrig
geblieben ist wie die Kirche St Georg
hier wird sie 1965 getauft nicht weit
entfernt die ST Josef Kirche die Familie
lebt direkt nebenan die Kinder gehen auf
eine städtische türkische
[Musik]
Schule meine Schwestern wurden in der
Schule ständig gemobt man hat sie hatchu
gerufen
unglubige verprügelt so war das während
meiner Kindheit wenn wir auf die Straße
gingen haben unsere Nachbarn komische
Gesten gemacht sie sagten dass wir drauf
spucken sollen und zeigten auf das Kreuz
deshalb war meine Mutter sehr vorsichtig
sie ließ uns nicht mehr so oft raus auf
die
Straße die Geschichte der Armenier in
der Region ist eine Geschichte von
Vertreibung Tod und Zerstörung dem
Völkermord ein Begriff den die Türkei
bis heute ablehnt fallen 1915 rund 1
Million Armenier zum Opfer nach der
Gründung der türkischen Republik lebt in
diabakir nur noch eine kleine Gemeinde
jede Aktion gegen Christen selbst im
weit entfernten Zypern war auch eine
Aktion gegen uns erinnert sich
[Musik]
Silva dieoperation von
1974 war der letzte nage im sag der
Christen inak es g
den Angst ist Geno anend wie Mut alle
hatten
Angst ihre Familie zieht fort nach
Istanbul dort lebt Silv bis heute wie
die meisten Armenier die noch im Land
sind in der ganzen Türkei sind es
vielleicht noch rund 60 000 von
einstmals eineinhalb
[Musik]
Millionen
in diabakir treffen sich zwei Frauen die
beide ihre Heimat verloren haben Silva
die Armenierin und Nevin soyukaya die
Kurdin soyukaya ist Archäologin wurde
wie Silva in diabakir geboren die
Altstadt in der beide aufwuchsen gibt es
nicht mehr nach Kämpfen zwischen
Regierungstruppen und Milizen der PKK im
Jahr 2015 stark zerstört wurde die
Altstadt fast völlig abgerissen und wird
nun durch neue seelenlose Stadthäuser
[Musik]
ersetzt wenn ich hiererkomme fühle ich
mich wie auf einem anderen Planeten für
mich fühlt es sich an als wäre das nicht
mehr meine Stadt es ist nicht die Stadt
in der ich geboren wurde nicht das
Viertel in dem ich geboren wurde ich
komme mir vor als wäre ich in einem
völlig anderen Platz und dieser Platz
bedeutet mir nichts
mehr zuerst wurde die armenische Kultur
zerstört dann wurde die assyrische
Kultur zerstört jetzt wurden die Kurden
die diese Kulturen am Leben hielten von
hier vertrieben 24000 Menschen sind von
hier weggegangen damit ist auch das
kurdische Leben von hier verschwunden
physisch aber auch geistig alles
verschwand mit den
menschenigentlich möchte ich diesen Teil
der Stadt nicht mehr besuchen den ich
mussehen Taus Jahre
ein trmerhaufen verwandelt
werden um die Neubausiedlung herum steht
noch die alte Stadtmauer sie ist
Weltkulturerbe schützte einst die
Altstadt und seine Bewohner oben auf dem
Hügel an den Hängen bis hinunter ins Tal
an die Ufer des Tigres liegen die
berühmten hefselgärten auch Sie Teil
Kulturerbes die Gärten sind
vorratammer at der
Kinder mein Bruder und mein Großvater
kamen sehr oft hierher mein Vater nicht
so oft wir hatten unglaublichen Spaß
hier es gab Musik wir haben Volkslieder
gesungen und es gab natürlich reichlich
zu essen dre Monate lang lieben die
Leute über Winter im Haus aber wenn die
kalten Monate vorbei waren wurde der
Garten zu unserem Wohnzimmer das gibt's
heute auch nicht
mehr
[Musik]
über diese verlorene Geschichte hat sie
ein Buch geschrieben ein Kochbuch weil
ich eine gute Köchin bin sagt silvera
weil die Rezepte von meinem Leben
erzählen und weil es um das gemeinsame
geht nicht um das
[Musik]
Trennende alle die in diesem Land leben
ernähen sich von dem dies Land daher
sind der Boden und der Tisch sehr
verbindend und so dachte ich es wäre
richtig diese Geschichte mit Hilfe von
Rezepten zu
[Musik]
schreiben dieses Gericht heißt perdel
PIL die bereiten die reisfüllung mit
Mandeln und Rosinen zu dann umwickeln
wir den Reis mit einem dünnen darmnetz
wir nennen es
und das Backen wir dann im Ofen es ist
ein Festmal und eines der Gerichte das
an Feiertagen auf den Tisch
[Musik]
gehört Reis Humus joghurtsuppe gefüllte
Auberginen und Paprika ein armenisches
Festmal in ihrer heimatstad diabakir sie
sind wieder zu Hause und fühlen sich
doch wie die ungeliebten Kinder der
[Musik]
Republik
ich wünschte wir könnten eine Republik
haben wie ein Vater ist der keine
Unterschiede zwischen den Kindern macht
wir sind jetzt nur noch sehr wenige wir
sind wie ein Lebewesen das vom
Aussterben bedroht ist und beschützt
werden muss wenn wir ganz verschwinden
wird die Türkei farblos und eintönig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
werden
ich heiße Ahmed TK bin in Mardin geboren
und hier in kasre kanjo groß geworden
1973 wurde ich ins Parlament gewählt
mache seit 50 Jahren aktiv
Politik Kre kanjo das Familiengutes
kanjo Clans kurdische Aristokratie
kurdischer
freiheitskf Clanchef und Respektsperson
für die einen Terrorist und Hassfigur
für viele andere es gibt Leute die
würden nicht mit ihm im selben Film
auftauchen
wollen meine Familie und der
Verwandtenkreis sind sehr groß auch die
Verbundenheit zwischen uns ist groß
nicht wie in Europa auch wenn jemand
nicht aus der gleichen Familie stammt
müssen wir trotzdem das Recht dieses
anderen Schützen wenn er unserem Clan
angehört
Türk stattet im Haus eines Verstorbenen
Schwagers den beileidsbesuch ab es ist
ein Patriarchat Männer und Frauen sitzen
getrennt im Frauenzimmer trifft Türk
seine ältere Schwester Cousinen Nichten
alles Familie sagt
er die Beileidsbekundung ist bei uns
Kurden sehr wichtig früher konnte das
Fest bis zu 10 15 Tage dauern wir haben
es auf Tage kzt um die Familien nicht
noch mehr zu
strapazieren bevor es das Festessen gibt
verlässt Türk die Familienfeier und
fährt einige Kilometer entfernt zum Haus
eines anderen
Clans auch dort findet eine
beileidsfeier statt Türk will seine
Aufwartung machen doch sein Besuch mit
einem ausländischen Fernsehteam im
Schlepptau provoziert das Oberhaupt der
anderen
Familie
[Musik]
es gibt in diesem Dorf einen Anhänger
von Erdogans Regierungspartei AKP der
fühlte sich durch unseren Auftritt
gestört wegen des Fernsehens das sei
Propaganda er hat ein paar spitze
Bemerkungen gemacht was euer Team da zu
suchen habe es sei doch eine
Beileidsbekundung er hat sich ein
bisschen darüber beschwert aber ich bin
nicht näher darauf
eingegangen
pünktlich zum Essen ist Türk wieder zu
Hause im Haus seines
Schwagers kurdische Familien wie der
kanjo Clan sind eine strenge
geschlossene Gesellschaft sie gehorchen
eigenen Gesetzen und sie fordern ihre
Rechte ein mit rund 19%
Bevölkerungsanteil sind die Kurden die
größte ethnische Minderheit der Türkei
Staatsgründer Attatürk habe die koden
damals als gleichwertige Mitglieder der
Volksgemeinschaft bezeichnet sagt
doch nach Ausrufung der Republik wurden
Existenz und Rechte der Kurden unter der
Doktrin des Nationalstaates nach und
nach zurückgenommen in einer Region in
der viele unterschiedliche Kulturen und
Identitäten Leben ist man mit einer
nationalistischen Logik vorgegangen was
heißt das ein Nationalstaat betreibt mit
Hilfe dieser Politik die Auflösung der
sogenannten anderen er predigt ein Volk
ein Staat das ist die Denkweise von
nationalsten für seine Gegner ist Türk
ein Sympathisant der terrormiliz PKK ein
Terrorist er sitzt jahrelang im
berüchtigten Gefängnis von diabakir wird
gefoltert doch er macht weiter
Politik wir Gefangenen waren vielleicht
nicht wie in den Konzentrationslagern
Hitlers dem Hunger ausgesetzt
aber was uns in diesen zwei Jahren die
wir dort waren an Folter angetan wurde
war vielleicht noch schlimmer wenn man
in der Politik ist und die rechte und
die Demokratie des kurdischen Volkes
verteidigt muss man jederzeit damit
rechnen ins Gefängnis gesteckt zu
[Musik]
werden das kurdische Neujahrsfest Ende
Mai in diabak veranstalter ist die
prokurdische Partei HDP die Staatsmacht
ist mit H schaften der Polizei
marschiert für Ahmed Türk ist diese
Machtdemonstration des Erdogan Regimes
nichts als Schikane jeder Ruf der Kurden
nach Selbstbestimmung solle mit allen
Mitteln verhindert werden dafür baue man
sinnlose Zäune und Sicherheitsschleusen
sagt
[Musik]
er sie wollen uns und die Massen trennen
dabei würden keine Probleme entstehen
wenn sie nicht eingreifen würden was
soll schon passieren unsere Leute
verstehen uns sie kommen um nevros zu
feiern
aber wenn Sie diese Sicherheitszonen
einrichten und Mauern zwischen uns und
dem Volk errichten zeigen die Menschen
eine Reaktion und das ist kein schönes
Bild schauen Sie tausende kurdische
Politiker sitzen heute in Haft nur weil
sie ihre Meinung und Gedanken frei
äußern weil sie ihre Rechte ihre
Identität ihre Kultur
einfordern man sagt immer die wollen die
Türkei teilen aber das wollen wir gar
nicht ganz im Gegenteil wir haben kein
Problem ürchen vol wiren mitürchen vol
in Frehe und
gleichheitben das ist
[Musik]
unsernis
ich bin alkem bin 22 und Studentin ich
arbeite in einer Tierarztpraxis als
[Musik]
Tierärztin Istanbul der
schwarzmeerstrand von Kilos alkim sch
kennt nur einen Präsidenten Reb TB
Erdogan und seine islamisch konservative
Regierung
[Musik]
ich habe keine großen Träume wie z.B ein
tolles Auto ein großes Haus oder so ich
will nur dass ich glücklich bin
glücklich mit meiner Arbeit und den
Menschen die mich
umgeben doch zur Zeit drehe sich in der
Türkei alles um die schlechte Wirtschaft
und um Politik sagt alkem sie lebt in
einer Wohnung die ihre Eltern
finanzieren ohne sie ich
nicht
l inem Land machen mssen oder ob ich
nachts ohne Probleme allein rausgehen
kann oder nicht ich möchte mein Leben
unbeschwert leben viele meiner Freunde
sind im Ausland wo es völlig egal ist
wer als Regierungschef gewählt wurde
aber bei uns ist das eine Frage von
Leben und Tod ich denke dass sich die
Politiker sehr weit von der Jugend
entfernt haben das sind alles Leute die
gedanklich noch aus dem Mittelalter
stammen egal wen ich mir anhö welchen
Politiker auch immer ich fühle mich von
keinem wirklich angesprochen
ön es ist Samstag Nachmittag alkim und
ihre Freundin schidem wollen am Abend
auf ein
technokonzert hat ihr Wirtschaftsstudium
gerade abgeschlossen und sucht nach
einem
Job die beiden wollen sich für den Abend
in Stimmung bringen doch dasget ist
knapp im Laden um die Ecke kostet eine
kleine flaschein
viel kostet auf dem Konzert ein einziges
[Musik]
Glas wir trinken bevor wir aufs Konzert
gehen dort gibt dann vielleicht nur noch
einen einzigen Drink so müssen wir das
halt
machen meine Mutter hat mir Sachen aus
ihrer Jugend erzählt ich einfach nicht
fassen kan dass sie bis nachts auf dem
taxiplatz unterwegs war getrunken und
gefeiert haben nachts um 3 oder 4 seien
sie als Mädels allein nach Haus gegangen
wenn ich das heute mache frage ich mich
wie komme ich nachts allein zurück nach
Hause darf ich mich so anziehen oder
lieber nicht das hat alles mit dem
konservativen Regime zu
tun zu jungen Leuten wie Ihnen habe die
Regierung den Kontakt verloren sagten
sie die Stimmung im Land sei
konservativer geworden
früher war das Nachtleben noch aktiver
in Istanbul es gab mehr Events mit der
Pandemie kam die Schließung aber dass
sich das bis heute bis September 2023
gehalten hat ist meiner Ansicht nach
Schuld der Regierung eigentlich sollten
Sie doch am Nachtleben viel verdienen
istanul sie doch Unmengen von Touristen
an aber das sind doch nicht die
Touristen die sie anziehen wollen genau
das istinlich nicht deren Klientel
deswegen nehmen Sie Abstand von
Nachtclubs und setzen eher auf andere
Sachen ja alles für die
Araber viel wichtiger als das aber ist
ihnen die Sorge um ihre Zukunft alles
sei so teuer geworden man könnte sich
viele Sachen nicht mehr
leisten icheon denchern nicht es kaufen
könen vom normalbürgerht du kannst dir
zwar eine Wohnung mieten aber dann fehlt
das Geld für die Möbel heiraten ist
totaler Luxus
hier ich wollte mit meinem Freund
zusammenziehen wir haben uns das mal
durchgerechnet wir müssten uns
finanziell von unseren Familien
unterstützen lassen damit wir uns das
leisten können und das wollen wir nicht
wir haben studiert einen Abschluss wir
sind erwachsen wir wollen auf unseren
eigenen beinenehen wir sind 23
Jahre und denken wieele der jungen
türkischen Generation es ist ihnen in
ihrer Heimat Türkei zu eng
[Musik]
geworden viele meiner Freunde sind zum
Studium ins Ausland gegangen ich hatte
auch die Möglichkeit aber ich wollte
damals nicht von meiner Familie und den
anderen Freunden Weg in den letzten
Jahren ja so in den letzten Jahren ist
es wirschaftlich und sozial immer
schwierorden ich habe nur ein Leben und
das möchte ich genießen ich will meinen
Kopf frei haben deswegen möchte ich im
Ausland promovieren ob ich danach auch
im Ausland bleibe oder in die Türkei
zurückkommen dahinter steht immer noch
ein
[Musik]
Fragezeichen
ich heiße jorgo sarbosan mein Spitzname
lautet Baba jorgo ich habe hier eine
[Musik]
Taverne gchada ist die größte Insel der
Türkei die Griechen nennen sie
imros jorgo sarbosan wurde auf imros
geboren
1939 vor 84 Jahren seine ganze Jugend
hier
verbracht jeden Samstag kamen hier 45
bis 50 junge Menschen Jungen wie Mädchen
zusammen bis in die frühen Morgenstunden
haben wir hier getanzt
1964 wurde dieser Platz enteignet und
eine Polizeiwache wurde gebaut damit war
das Tanzlokal nicht mehr da so war das
was will man
machen Besuch am Grab des Vaters
nach Gründung der Republik wurden zwei
von Griechen besiedelte esinseln der
Türkei zugesprochen im Zuge des
sogenannten
bevölkerungsaustausches verließen die
meisten Griechen die Türkei einige
tausend blieben auf Gerda doch in den
60er Jahren kam es zu Enteignungen
Schulen wurden geschlossen jorgo verließ
die Insel ging nach Istanbul studierte
Chemie heiratete leitete eine eigene
Firma aber in Gedanken war ich immer
hier ich habe 38 Jahre in Istanbul
gelebt aber jede Nacht war ich in meinen
Träumen
hier jorgo kehrte
1996 zurück auf die Insel seiner
Kindheit er baute das Haus seiner Eltern
wieder auf kaufte sich Schafe eröffnete
eine Taverne jorgo wollte das Leben der
altgriechen nach göada zurückbringen
doch es gab nicht mehr viele von ihnen
die meisten waren
weggegangen es hatte alle woanders hin
verschlagen von Australien über Amerika
bis nach Griechenland nur ein kleiner
Teil blieb in der Türkei einen Zugvogel
verschleckt es dorthin wohin der Wind
hinträgt heute feiern sie wieder ihr
griechisch orthodoxes Marienfest immer
im August dann werden Lämmer
geschlachtet wird gemeinsam gebetet dann
gegessen und
getanzt sie sind bis heute dabei die
Wunden zu heilen die der republikgündung
schlug als er diesen
Bevölkerungsaustausch mit Griechenland
vereinbarte und Tausende auf beiden
Seiten ihre Heimat verlassen
[Musik]
mussten das war ein großer Fehler denn
die Muslime oder Türken die aus
Griechenland aus Kreta oder Mazedonien
kamen konnten es hier niemandem Recht
machen die von hier gingen die Griechen
aus Anatolien Istanbul und Ismir die
konnten es in Griechenland niemandem
Recht machen der eine wird hier als
Ungläubiger gesehen der andere dort
drüben als türkische Sat also irgendwann
reicht wir sind doch alle nur
Menschen das Marienfest ist das
wichtigste religiöse Fest
auf Jund sagt kam das Christentum auch
auf unsere
Insel damals kam ein Missionar sein Name
war konon er kam mit seinen Priestern
und Mönchen und sie überzeugten unsere
Vorfahren mit dem Schwert vom
Christentum es blieb ihn also gar nichts
anderes übrig als zum Christentum
[Musik]
überzutreten Heimkehrer wie die beiden
kennen sich noch aus Istanbul jorgo war
dort mit Stelios Vater
befreundet natürlich erinnere ich mich
an ihn als Kind er ist immer noch ein
kleines Kind er hat uns zwar immer
geärgert trotzdem hat er uns sehr
gern stelio Berber ist Musiklehrer und
Direktor der griechischen Schule auf
G er wurde hier geboren ging dann als
Kind mit seinen Eltern nach Istanbul
doch auch sein Herz hing all die Jahre
immer an dieser
[Musik]
Insel ich lebte in Istanbul gemeinsam
mit meiner Familie als es nach der
Pandemie die Chance gab als Musiklehrer
hierher an die Schule zu kommen haben
wir dieses Angebot als Familie
wahrgenommen
vor 10 Jahren wurde die Schule wieder
eröffnet seitdem dürfen die Kinder
wieder in griechischer Sprache
unterrichtet
[Musik]
werden die Schulen waren 49 Jahre
geschlossen in dieser Zeit wdenhr
Generationen nicht hier geboren sie
wuchsen an anderen Orten auf und es fand
ein Bruch mit der Insel statt dies
wieder rückgängig machen zu wollen und
an den Ursprung zurückzukehren das war
nicht
einfach gemeinsamer Protest von Griechen
und ihren türkischen Nachbarn gegen das
Verbot einer Fotoausstellung über die
Enteignung der altgriechen auf der Insel
die türkischen Behörden verweigern die
Genehmigung
ihr stellt sich nicht die Frage ob
Grieche Türke oder Kurde hier geht es um
die Meinungsfreiheit durch Konfrontation
soll eine Kulturveranstaltung verhindert
werden dagegen whren wir uns alle
gemeinsam und ich denke das ist eine
sehr wertvolle
[Musik]
Aktion mit einer Unterschriftenaktion
stellen sie sich gegen die Entscheidung
der Stadtverwaltung wollen sogar
Strafanzeige stellen gegen den der das
Verbot durch seinen Protest erwirkt
hatte wir akzeptieren keine Beleidigung
der unsere griechischen Freunde
ausgesetzt sind dafür werden wir bis zum
Ende kämpfen wir werden alles Notwendige
tun und wenn es eine Straftat ist wird
eine Strafanzeige
gestellt ich denke es ist falsch
Kulturveranstaltungen wie diese zu
verbieten wir sind freie Menschen jede
Kultur sollte das Recht haben hier zu
leben egal welche es ist es gibt hier
keine Feindseligkeiten oder Hassreden es
ist nur eine Ausstellung es ist
Kunst in Bab Jorgos Taverne ist die
historische Feindschaft zwischen
Griechen und Türken sehr weit weg es ist
der Abend des marienfests der Abend an
dem sie alle gemeinsam
[Musik]
feiern
es ist das erste Mal dass ich auf bin es
ist das erste Mal dass ich auf so einem
Fest
bin offen gesagt ich war immer sehr
neugierig draf ich habe griechische
Freunde wir haben die gleiche Kultur sie
ist sich sehr ähnlich
[Musik]
Esser ist Touristin aus Thessaloniki
ihre Großeltern wurden aus der Türkei
nach Griechenland Zwangs umgesiedelt sie
ist mit ihrer Mutter und ihren Töchtern
gekommen seit drei Generationen haben
wir diesen Schmerz geliebt aber jetzt
tanzen unsere Kinder zusammen die vierte
Generation ein Kind war griechisch und
das andere türkisch niem mchte diesenz
wir sind zwei Völker die so miteinander
verschmolzen sind unsere Freuden und
unsere Sorgen sind sich so ähnlich doch
es ist immer die Politik die spaltet und
ausgrenzt letztlich sind wir alle Kinder
Gottes sagt jorgo sarbosan die Türkei
ist unsere Heimat hier in diesem Boden
will ich begraben werden aber bitte noch
nicht so
bald früer allen Festen dai heute sind
es die jungen Menschen die das
Organisieren wo ich noch helfen kann
versuche ich das zu tun ich danke
euch und ich wünsche allen ein
glückliches
[Musik]
Leben sechs Biografien sechs Blicke auf
ein Land mit einer langen wechselvollen
Geschichte dass es sich und seinen
Menschen nie leicht gemacht
[Musik]
hat